welcome to part three of our series on
using G Suite api's for student
developers
this is developer advocate Wesley Chun
previously we'd discuss how to use G
suite REST API so now we'll switch gears
to show you a higher level way of
accessing those aps will switch from
Python to JavaScript and drop all the
security code as it's automatically
generated for you by Google Apps Script
so what is Apps Script well I think of
it as another Google secret but it's
actually not a secret
nor is it well-kept since it's been out
for over a decade it is Java Script but
instead of using rest and HTTP with
OAuth you use built-in objects to talk
to Google api's also you don't have to
write the auth code because it's
automatically generated for you now
while it is server-side like node it's
more like using JavaScript as a
programming language rather than for
asynchronous event-driven web apps now a
one-line or describing Apps Script looks
like this it's service meaning no VMs
cuz we host and run your code it helps
automate repeated tasks extends the
functionality of G suite editors
connects to non Google Cloud products
like Maps analytics and YouTube and lets
you access external databases or other
online services now let's get started
with a Google sheet it's got many
functions but are there any magic ones
you know like that only sheets has well
how about Google Finance it's a great
way to pull up the latest stock price on
your favorite company cool all right
well we'll come back to functions later
but for now let's code sheets without
using a REST API is that possible yep
can do just pull down the script editor
under tools and here's your hello world
a one-line JavaScript application that
writes hello world into the upper left
cell of a sheet you know a one look ma
no o op code yet the prompt still
appears when you save and run it now the
output is as expected
check the video for a longer Apps Script
intro now back to magic functions here's
another one google translate now those
are cool but they're Google products
right finance and translate well what if
I wanted to write a function that
checked today's Bitcoin prices well that
function doesn't exist but using Apps
Script you can create custom functions
here I'm calling
one of the many Bitcoin ApS out there to
get today's price check out the sample
code if you get a chance and woohoo I've
just created my own custom function now
what can we do with this well instead of
hello world we've got a real piece of
data now happens to be the address for
the Google New York office there's also
a header row so bear in mind we need to
read cell a2 now here's a four line app
that does something kind of useful like
before we access the sheets active sheet
but instead of writing to a cell we read
the address from it but we can also pass
that address to Google Maps and ask it
to create a map with a pin or a marker
on that address finally we can call the
Gmail API to send this map to my friend
to tell them to come to the Google New
York office to meet me for lunch check
out the video for more details now where
can you go from here maybe your sales
team needs to visit several customers in
New York or perhaps you manage a book
club well create a custom map for
members coming to the next Meetup now
don't forget maps also has walking and
public transit directions all accessible
from Apps Script as well now we've shown
how you can create custom functions and
sheets bound scripts using Apps Script
what else can it do well if you've ever
heard of add-ons before they're also
part by Apps Script add-ons let you
extend the functionality of Google Docs
sheets slides forms and Gmail it also
powers app maker add scripts and Google
data studio community connectors now
let's look at add-ons starting with
slides every want to make a progress bar
for your decks to let you and the
audience know how much is left
while slide bars are not exactly native
to presentation software but we can
build an add-on that extends the
functionality of Google slides here's
the progress bar code it calculates how
many slides you have in total then
creates relatively sized rectangles on
each slide check out our blog posts and
video for a deeper dive into this sample
next let's say you're a busy working
professional going on a business trip
you want to get reimbursed for your
airfare and hotel right well for that
you need to create what is called an
expense report for your manager but
since you get all of your receipts in
Gmail why can't you do the expense
report there well you can with a gmail
add-on here you can see that
we're in kind of in Gmail but let's give
you the whole picture Gmail add-on show
up in the right nav ours does expenses
so we picked an icon that looks like a
receipt where sort of looks like a
receipt one awesome bonus with Gmail
add-ons is that they run on web and
mobile meeting you don't have to write
two versions of your app and they work
seamlessly on both the only difference
is that the add-on icons show up on the
bottom on mobile
now the add-on extracts irrelevant data
from the receipt like the date the
amount the vendor then pre fills in and
pops up this form all you do is supply a
link to Google sheet and once all of
your expenses are locked successfully
you'll have a sheet with all of your
expenses which you can export as PDF and
send to your manager for approval cool
right I'll check out the blog post and
video for more info and code snippets
now that you know how to use Apps Script
and G suite rest api's join my
colleagues for the next set of videos
demoing medium-size apps that do cool
things with these G suite developer
tools this is Wesley Chun from Google
and thanks for watching
[Music]